ja leute herzlich kommen zu diesem video
viele von euch haben wahrscheinlich auch
gar nicht mitgekriegt dass unsere kleine
mal die hündin von der sophie und von
mir abgehauen das letztes wochenende
also vielleicht hat das mitgekriegt und
einige von euch haben auch gefragt hey
wie es jetzt ausgegangen wie genau
dieses video steckt und da dachte ich
mir eine story ist einfach nicht lange
genug der machen jetzt ein video und
zwar machen wir das video nicht einfach
nur auf einem kanal sondern einen
zweiten teil auf ihrem kanal ja dann
stand ich da auf jeden fall mit der mai
an der leine vom saturn habe ich extra
schön in den schatten gestellt und alles
und dachte mir so alles von entspannt
und aus dem nichts
zuckt die zusammen und kraftlos wie eine
gestörte dass ich gar nicht mehr
irgendwie kontrollieren konnte mit der
hand noch zuzugreifen und die leine fest
sollten denn dies mit der leine einfach
durch meine finger quasi durch
geflutscht und einfach los gesamt 4
gestörte eine sekunde ich gedacht okay
wenn du es hinterher rennt wenn die
renten weiter und ich habe aber gesehen
was für den modus die war und ich wusste
sofort okay da bringt stehen bleiben und
rufen überhaupt nichts ich muss
hinterher erstens finde ich die nie
wieder und ich wollte eben die sowie
abholen bin dann eben zum saturn
gegangen und habe dann nur gehört wie
die so viel geschrieben hat danach sie
mir ja okay da ist sophie cool endlich
gefunden daten fällig sobald dachte okay
dann wird die man halt irgendwie dahin
pinkeln oder irgendwas keine ahnung beim
zweiten mal hatte ich das mal schon gar
nicht mehr so freundlich angehört und da
habe ich dann auch die gerne mal gesehen
wie die ein paar gesamtlage über die
hauptstraße darüber düst und ich weiß
nicht genau was ich mir dabei gedacht
habe da ich habe wahrscheinlich gar
nichts gedacht in so einem moment da
übernehmen dann halt einmal irgendwelche
instinkte und als sie dann eben auf mich
zugegangen ist habe ich mich da eben
halt vor sie hingestellt und ich wusste
jetzt auch nicht was ich dazu sage dass
ich hätte jetzt nicht einfach so ruhig
bleiben können wir sagen ja mal komm her
weil da werde ich schon direkt da
gewesen dass ich habe es halt versucht
sie einfach zu fangen und es hat auch es
war so krass ich habe mich darauf diese
straße geworfen und es war so knapp wie
mir ihre leine einfach da nicht in die
finger geraten konnte
doch so genau
im weiteren verlauf muss ich so oft an
diesen moment denken
wo ist einfach es war so knapp und ich
meine jetzt ist es halt voll easy wir
wissen halt die meisten da und jetzt ist
alles gut aber die sich die drei vier
tage da war man sich halt immer nicht
mehr sicher wenn man den hund jetzt
malen
das wiedersehen und der moment an dem
ich mich immer wieder musste und kann
ich jetzt denke die mühe haben wenn ich
rede die so ein ball auf jeden fall erst
wenn dieser erste versuch sie zu fangen
nicht geklappt hat bin ich aber weiter
gerannt habe mich umgedreht und bin ihr
hinterher über die straße gerannt und da
war alles ziemlich viel verkehr deswegen
das team erst mal her recht rüber und
natürlich kann ich ja nicht einmal
drüber habt dann so mega cool wie im
film
die den verkehr angehalten und bin
darüber gerannt und was dann echt krass
war ich bin ihr denn her gerannt und
sieht natürlich viel schneller als ich
also wieder hast du den renault war
letztmals so reden aber ich war es
ultras dann zu sehen wie sich das dann
abläuft diesem moment weil die nächste
weiß noch nie passiert ich ganz was
neues im film unscheinbar ist sowas
schon mal passiert dass ein haustier
wegrennt aber noch nicht wenn ihr dann
hinterher gerannt und in jede straße in
die ich da ein neuer eingebogen winter
standen immer schon drei leute die in
die richtung in die sie ab gedonnert ist
geguckt haben und sie herum gedreht
haben und dann direkt wussten dass ich
ja hinterher auch weil ich halt
aufgebracht war und gerannt bin und soll
ich weil sie über 1 kilometer die mal
verfolgt die sogar an unserer wohnung
vorbei ist und das musste ich eben weil
die leute da stand nur mir die richtung
gezeigt haben und leider habe ich dann
in einem gewissen punkt die fährte
verloren und ab dem punkt es war schon
so heiß an diesem tag ab dem punkt
konnte war schon ihr müsst verstehen ich
bin da wirklich so schnell gerannt ich
konnte und nicht ab dem punkt habe ich
wirklich gefühlt geblutet und es war
echt krass und er war dann so ein
freundlicher obdachloser mann der mir
auch geholfen hat uns derart zu halten
fahrrad und da dachte ich mir gut ich
kann jetzt nicht mehr laufen
da habe ich ihn gefragt ob ich mir nicht
so ein fahrrad für 100 euro kaufen
könnte da kommt so überlegt so
dann hat er seine fahrer verkauft und
ich dachte erst erfolgreich dass ein
fahrrad gibt und dass ich mir
aufgefallen wie gut die gänge
funktioniere nicht und das ist immer im
letzten gang und man kann einfach nicht
mit diesem fahrrad losfahren wenn man
nicht das vorerst mal losrennen und
anschrift ich bin halt auf dem weg
eigentlich schon hyperventiliert ich hab
schon gar keine luft bekommen ich bin
glaube ich keine 150 meter gerannt und
wir sind schon die tränen in die augen
gestiegen weil ich so ein schreck
gekriegt habe und einfach keine luft
mehr bekommen dass es dann quasi einfach
nach hause gelaufen bin in der hoffnung
dass die beiden schon quasi wieder zu
hause sind in der wohnung besitzen und
ich kann heute die wohnung rein und da
war natürlich keinen thomas und keine
mai und vor lauter panik ich jetzt meine
mama angerufen der mutter dann erst mal
ruft die polizei da habe ich polizei
angerufen habe da meine nummer
hinterlegt habe gesagt dass das ja auch
nicht so dass sie aufpassen sollen weil
die sehr viel angst vor menschen hat vor
allem von männern und vor allem wenn die
dicke jacken haben oder halt auch eine
schutzweste wie polizisten auf tragen da
habe ich auch noch bei der feuerwehr
angerufen und keine ahnung also dreimal
mehr wirkt bei jedem tierheim in ganz
nordrhein-westfalen gefühl das ist die
tierheime war meine mutter weil ich das
schon wieder los gegangen bin habe ich
ja ich kenne jetzt suchen auf der suche
hat das quasi parallel alle möglichen
leute angerufen die mir eingefallen sind
die ich ihnen könnte also könnte also
ich hab da glaube ich habe versucht sie
zu erreichen ich habe freunde von mir
angerufen ich habe ihn angerufen und
sebastian und die haben dann auch
geantwortet und sind dann auch in
direkter hackman standort und ich helfe
dir suchen ich darf mir so egal da
stücken ihrer leicht mit dem fußball
nicht viel zu langsam mein fahrrad hatte
einen platten und ich fahre den dollar
um und sucht die man dann höre ist keine
so gute idee
was wenn ich dann verband ich bin dann
kann sie den park gefahr mit dem e
roller wo ich meistens mit der gassi
gegangen bin bei einmal hat sondern ein
bisschen zuviel geruckelt und ich bin
gerade weg über am boden drüber
geschlittert und habe mir mehrere
schiff unten und verstauchte angebrochen
dass man weiß es nicht handgelenk geholt
mir einfach alles weh getan und auch
mein kind war
hier sehen wir ein paar wunderschöne
bilder von wunderschönen wunderschönes
aus welche in meinem kind in blaubeuren
reingefallen
ja und dann kamen auf jeden fall zwei
fußgänger zu mir und haben krankenwagen
rufen ich war währenddessen mit
sebastian unterwegs und hatte eben nach
dem mann gesucht in dahin stellt man sie
besser wir kommen dann irgendwann
plötzlich ein anruf von irgendeinem
typen über ihr handy aber die haben
gesagt hat ja diese filiale in den e
roller unfall und der notarzt kommt
jetzt und also ich meine klar dass es
hier passiert ist schlimm genug aber
letztendlich ist sie halt aufs maul
gefallen auf einem feldweg
aber für uns hat sich angehört das werde
jetzt von dem auto zusammengefahren
wollen und wer jetzt billy kopp gefühlt
in die nächste notaufnahme rhein gibt
dort war das da war die stimmung
wirklich richtig gut ja die war dann
erstmal im krankenhaus hatte ich dann
auch geklärt dass sie nicht sterben und
ich lasse erst mal zwei stunden lang in
der notaufnahme vom krankenhaus in köln
und hatten panik mal das leben hätte ich
einfach nichts tun konnte
ich wäre am liebsten einfach
aufgestanden und werfer weiter gefallen
haben jetzt einfach alles so wehgetan
hat sich nicht aufstehen wollte oder
konnte und hab dann war unser alltag hat
logischerweise komplett weg und das ging
halt die nächsten drei tage so dass wir
ständig nur die mal gesucht haben da wir
eben über instagram paar sich aufmerksam
darüber gemacht haben dass die margen
weg ist haben ja auch einige hinweis
gekriegt aber ich glaube die waren dann
letztendlich wirklich alle entweder
irgendwie falsch sichtungen was ja
nichts schlimmes ich meine leute halten
johnston und denken das thema ist ja
okay wenn sie sich dann bei uns melden
aber einige haben auch gesagt ja ich hab
die mal und die selbst bei uns dann halt
nicht mal ein bild schicken wollte und
ich kann dir kein bild von den magic
weil ich muss dir besser ein
die erste schon dem moment wo die gesagt
haben die haben die mal bei sich zu
hause und wasserdichte im moment war
eigentlich klar dass es nicht unbedingt
sein kann weil die halt wie gesagt in
panik modus war und auch von fremden
leuten extremer angst hat und sie lässt
sich nicht einfach mal so von
irgendjemandem einfangen und das ist
einfach nur wirklich also da war ich
echt also ich wusste ja dass menschen
abgrundtief scheiße sein können aber da
war ich echt richtig hart enttäuscht
sogar nochmal weil in so einem moment
also vielleicht haben dass ich immer den
gut vorstellen ich kann jetzt nicht mehr
richtig vorstellen wie krank diese
situation dann einfach wirklich im
moment war aber das letzte was du
brauchst wenn du da ein grundsatz den du
womöglich in dem moment nie wieder sehen
wirst ist jemand der sagt ja ich habe
den hund aha
doch nicht krank die idee zu kommen
hoffnung zu machen also muss man nicht
verstehen und warum diese ganzen falsch
sichtungen gar nicht richtig sein können
tja das erfahrt ihr in der auflösung
wann wir die meisten kunden haben also
das war recht was wir noch alles
unternommen haben das rad gefunden haben
das war auf jeden fall also null
schlafen also echt ich glaube die
meisten leute würden sagen dass wir
komplett geisteskrank nicht jetzt
überreagiert dabei alt und zu wenig
geschont haben auf jeden fall aber ich
kann im moment meine versuche einfach
alles mögliche in seiner macht stehende
zu tun um diesen wieder zu finden und da
ist dann einfach schwer daran zu sagen
ja okay jetzt pause rächten schlage ich
schlafe jetzt mal acht stunden und film
an weil die folge auch meine pause daran
denken hatten wir dann kann ich würde
sagen den rest das video steht ja auf
dem kanal von einer alten sophie erfahrt
ihr dann auch wie sein vater dann auch
wie wir die süße kleine mal gekriegt
haben wieder junge es war so ein zufall
einfach mal so viel glück na ja er werde
so fahren übrigens hat ihm auch harmlose
promo jetzt mal am ende übrigens hat ihm
auch noch einmal schauen könnte auch
wann folgen dass ich dir über das geile
bilder von ihr könnt ihr auch auf inseln
folgen daher sie gehe hier ihr könnt ihr
auch genau wer nämlich auch dieser reise
begleiten möchte diesen kanal und dann
sehen uns im nächsten wieder gut
[Musik]